hey what's up everybody it is monday
january 31st 2022 i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message we are
live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv and this is a very very
exciting day for me first off most
importantly
as you know the truck from la with all
of our stuff arrived here in miami
finally on friday we've been unpacking
all weekend it's been a little haywire
around here you still might hear some
banging and some other things as things
are being moved and we're doing some
patchwork and other such nonsense but i
have my desk my old trusty desk it's
back my old trusty chair you may see
that my posture will be a little bit
better i felt i was sitting in a like a
stool kind of situation like a bar stool
and i felt the last couple shows i was a
little like this but today i'm back i'm
sitting up straight with my shoulders
back and i'm very excited and speaking
of sitting up straight or standing up
straight with one's shoulders back there
is a rumor and i don't want to say
anything out of school but there is a
rumor
that a guy named jordan peterson a
little-known canadian psychologist
is in miami this evening doing a show at
the fillmore theater and then there is
another rumor a rumor that is running in
parallel with that rumor that some guy
perhaps that you may be watching right
now
might
be opening for that little known
canadian psychologist tonight as a
reunion of their 120-some odd 20-country
show tour that they did throughout 2018
and 2019 this might be the one night in
miami in the free state of florida that
the reunion show kicks in it is possible
that's what i'm hearing i'm also hearing
the tickets are unavailable that it's
completely sold out you might want to
look into that if you're in the south
florida area uh we shall see we have
ladies and jelly spoons a
jam packed show for you i usually say
ladles and jelly spoons i said ladies
and jelly spoons right there it's mixing
it up for you uh we got an absolutely
jam-packed show like i feel like this
show is as thick with the type of stuff
that i like doing sometimes we get a
show you know sometimes it's like ah is
there enough news to talk about we got a
one or two stories let's see but this
show is just like going to be like
punching through a brick wall uh first
off the big thing and i think this is
the most important cultural thing and
political thing at the moment uh is this
joe rogan versus spotify situation and
that artists musicians
free speech warriors
such as neil young and joni mitchell are
fleeing spotify because of
misinformation specialist joe rogan so
we're going to talk about that there's a
lot to talk about it's actually sort of
permeating through all throughout
society right now not not just the
cultural war and the big tech thing but
it's leaking into the political thing
there's business aspects to this it's
it's super interesting and rogan has
responded to some of the nonsense then
the really the story outside of our
borders that's the big one and again i
mentioned this on friday it's just not
going to be picked up by the mainstream
media until we absolutely force them to
pick it up and i think we're maybe
getting to the precipice of that is this
incredible convoy of truckers that have
been going to ottawa in canada thousands
and thousands of
people possibly the largest uh truck
convoy in world history to protest the
the mandates and uh the lockdowns and
the rest of the nonsense and justin
trudeau has gone into hiding apparently
because it's apparent you know these
people are obviously nazis that was joke
and now he has covet i guess that's some
timing on that one huh so we'll talk
about that then
the sort of theme of the show last week
of what's going on with the last
remaining good liberals i'm talking
about bill maher the barry weiss types
well bill maher went on an awesome rant
on his show on friday talking about
exactly what i was addressing which is
are the good liberals ever going to
really fight the left and what is left
on the left and has liberalism just sort
of collapsed on itself well bill maher
stepped up to the plate i sent some
people over at a show or watching this
program and then finally this lindsey
graham guy who is a republican senator
he uh he's repeating some of the racist
nonsense coming from joe biden about how
we have to have a black female supreme
court justice not a native american they
don't care about them not a not an
indian you know not a
asian black she's got to be black so
we're going to talk about that
and before i get to any of that we've
got to show you this picture just put up
the picture this is just nuts this is
from hamel law on twitter this is last
night at the rams game at sofi stadium
here in la
and she wrote did you enjoy at gavin
newsom did you enjoy uh san francisco
versus la tonight at sofi stadium love
your gorgeous
maskless face unmask my children now
please my toddler five-year-old and
seven-year-old are going to school in
l.a county tomorrow and will be sent
home if they unmask like this even
outside so of course there's gavin
newsom that evil freak he's standing
next to magic johnson who of course i
love magic johnson eric garcetti the
mayor of la was also there by the way i
do know that every time i gratuitously
mention california as i've done right
now i have to put five dollars towards
my fleeing california fund which we will
give to somebody at the end of the year
to help them flee california let's say
i've done it about 10 times so far it's
at about 50 bucks here's another five
we're at about 55 bucks michael make
sure we have a spreadsheet and we're
counting that and you know blah blah
blah
but
i would say generally speaking like if
you don't get it at this point they want
your children masked they want them
depressed they don't care they think
they are better than you they are the
elites and you are peons leave la leave
california there is no shame that will
work there is no honest assessment of
what's going on that will work there is
no scientific data to prove anything
that they're doing all of this stuff is
designed it's them versus you i'm with
you but you have to be for you and you
know where you can be for you florida so
get to florida or get to tennessee or
get to texas that's your chance you
gotta leave you gotta leave okay all
right let's talk about this rogue
inverse spotify situation because it's
escalating and as i said it's sort of
leaking into like every part of society
right now and it should actually because
this fight over free speech and how we
are uh ruled over by big tech and how
that is connected to how governments can
control us and the rest of it this is
big stuff so uh you know this prince
harry he married this uh megan lady uh
they have uh decided that they're gonna
do a non-profit devoted to combating
misinformation and now they have gotten
involved in this uh we've got a
statement from prince harry and prince
is she princess technically she's on her
way to be princess
duchess she's the duchess okay there you
go the duchess so prince and duchess
here's what they said about this whole
rogan spotify misinformation brew ha
since the inception of archwell that's
their foundation dealing with
misinformation we have worked to address
the real-time global misinformation
crisis hundreds of millions of people
are affected by the serious harms of
rampant myths and disinformation every
day last april our co-founders began
expressing the concerns to our partners
at spotify about the all too real
consequences of covet 19 misinformation
on its platform we have continued to
express our concerns to spotify to
ensure changes to its platform are made
to help address this public health
crisis we look to spotify to meet this
moment and are committed to continuing
our work together as it does so of
course what these people are saying and
what sort of the mainstream narrative
right now is saying is that there's this
popular
podcaster this joe rogan guy who sits
down with people for three hours and he
sits down with all sorts of scary people
some of the people that he sits down
with that are so scary include dr robert
malone who was basically the founder of
the mrna technology that the vaccines
are based upon uh so he sits down with
with these people and he talks about
things and that's very very scary to a
certain set of people who just want you
to get information accept it is true and
live life accordingly well rogan's not
taking it lying down and he released
about a nine minute instagram video
we've got two clips from it here you go
the podcast has been accused of
spreading dangerous misinformation
specifically about two episodes a little
bit about some other ones but
specifically about two one with dr peter
mccullough and one with dr robert malone
dr peter mccullough is a cardiologist
and he is the most published physician
in his field in history
dr robert malone owns nine patents on
the creation of mrna vaccine technology
and is at least partially responsible
for the creation of the technology that
led to mrna vaccines
both these people are very highly
credentialed very intelligent very
accomplished people and they have an
opinion that's different from the
mainstream narrative i wanted to hear
what their opinion is
okay
first off good on you joe rogan
defending what you've done defending the
guests that you've had on and defending
their right to say what they think and
as he pointed out they are quite
credentialed so these are people who are
uh well versed in these issues and
should be allowed to say these things
now by the way if they were at
well-versed and if they were just sort
of nut bags or conspiracy theorists or
everything else you're still allowed to
speak you are here in the united states
you still are allowed okay at least for
now um so so rogan is making a good
point there now already though you can
see that there's a little bit of a
problem here the fact that he now feels
that he has to address this
shows you the encroachment right so
you've got the the prince and the
duchess and they're coming after him
with their misinformation
campaign to stop misinformation
and now you've got the entire machine
coming down and we're going to pressure
spotify to do things so rogan already
instead of doing what he does on a
normal day which is probably work out
and you know watch some mma stuff and
prepare for the podcast and do whatever
else he does cooks a lot of elk meat etc
he already feels that he has to defend
himself to some degree now even though
it is there are times when you
absolutely do have to defend yourself
you can see how they've moved on him
they've moved on him a bit and he went
on uh to talk about what spotify is
going to do because they've already
addressed the ceo address what they're
going to do about this scary joe rogan
program
one of the things that spotify wants to
do that i agree with is that at the
beginning of these controversial
podcasts like specifically ones about
kovid is to put a disclaimer and say
that you should speak with your
physician and that these people and the
opinions that they express
are contrary to the opinions of uh the
consensus of experts which i think is
very important
sure have that on there i'm very happy
with that
ah very happy with that okay this is
where this gets mixed up and just for
the record i'd be happy to talk to rogan
about this uh so this is not attacking
joe rogan but this is where the danger
kicks in spotify is basically saying
we're going to put these warnings on
things now we've all seen these warnings
right every time you go on instagram now
they're putting warnings all over every
meme like twitter puts warnings on
things if you say things that you know
four months ago were conspiracy theories
that are now true like we all we all
know that game and how that is played uh
but rogan saying that he's for this idea
is dangerous because everything is
controversial why is it that that covid
related misinformation or covet related
controversy is something that should
have to be dealt with differently like
you could talk about
the middle east is that controversial
yeah so we have warnings on that the
person that we have on who's a historian
may not know absolutely everything about
everything and may have their own
personal views that they're going to
share right now
literally everything you could bring on
two people to talk about mma as rogan
does and there could be controversial
opinions on that related to transgender
people fighting biological males and
we better have a warning on that there
is no topic that is worth listening to
for three hours certainly that is not
controversial to some degree so already
by putting this warning on well first
off i don't think anyone's paying
attention to these warnings so spotify's
spotify is throwing the mob a little
something here and maybe in rogan's mind
and i can certainly understand this when
the pressure builds enough and you've
just had enough of the headache you're
like ah you know what let them throw the
freaking warning on because nobody's
gonna pay attention to it and it doesn't
matter however you can see that there
obviously is a slippery slope here
because this is sort of what they did to
alex jones at some point like the
machine just went on him and it doesn't
even matter what it was about anymore
this is about the principal not the
person like eventually you put enough
warnings on enough rogan things and then
enough advertisers drop out and then
next thing you know spotify is looking
at the books and they're going boy an
awful lot of people do
watch and listen to joe rogan but we
don't make any money on that so maybe we
should bring that neil young back he's a
cash cow man
but
all that being said there's it's not as
if there's no precedent for this and
it's not as if there was no way of
seeing that some of this stuff with
spotify was going to happen because you
guys may remember about a year and a
half ago when when rogan took the jump
so in essence left youtube as his main
platform and then moved over to spotify
spotify did censor i think it's 46 it's
45 to 50. it's a little unclear
of joe rogan's videos we've got the full
list here i'm just going to read a
couple of the names it was over 40
people these episodes that were censored
included comedian chris dalia alex jones
of course comedian and my friend brian
callan sargon of akkad carl benjamin who
is a good guy and an old school liberal
gavin mcginnis eddie bravo joey diaz war
machine david seaman brian redman i'm
not even sure who all of these people
are
but the simple truth is there is
there was a warning sign here right like
that's what this is about when he signed
the deal he took 200 million bucks and
i'm not i'm not disparaging him and no
one has ever offered me 200 million
dollars i don't know what i would do in
the face of 200 million and maybe they
went through every single one and they
said this is why and this and all of
that stuff okay even though some of
those people i i think are his friends
and comedians the point is that there
was a track record there of this is what
this company
stands for so spotify said these are 46
or so scary interviews i don't know that
anyone has ever hurt because of any of
those interviews these are usually words
if anyone made a direct threat of
violence or actually murdered somebody
say or tried to sell drugs something
like that these people would be dealt
with by the law
but he did sign on the dotted line he
said okay i'll take the 200 million
which i've heard is actually much more
than that i'll take it and you can get
rid of those so we should have had some
sense that this was going to come and
again i actually don't mean that as a as
a real judgment call on rogan it's just
to paint a full picture of what's going
on here with spotify and and any
relationship myself included that anyone
who talks for a living or who interviews
for a living or who communicates ideas
for a living any of us that do this that
enter a relationship with a company that
we don't control
are going to have this risk it's exactly
why i started locals it's exactly why we
merged with rumble because i i know the
people that are in charge and that may
not be a perfect situation it's it's
pretty damn close and we're doing the
best we can
and i just had a bunch of meetings in
sarasota over over in uh
at rumble's new offices in sarasota to
discuss all this stuff um but that is
the problem when when you don't own your
stuff completely when someone else is
paying your salary you're always
beholden to somebody so i'm i'm very
impressed that rogan's fighting back but
you can see that the machine moved a
little bit now there'll be warnings now
there'll be warnings but that made me
think why is it that the machine
never puts warnings on things when
there's misinformation from the other
side because it's not as if there's no
evidence that the other side might put
out misinformation conor i think let's
do the matter clip first how about that
let's jump to rachel maddow spreading
misinformation it means that instead of
the vaccine being able excuse me it
means for instead of the virus being
able to hop from person to person to
person to person spreading and spreading
sickening some of them but not all of
them and the ones that it doesn't stick
and don't know they have it and then
they give it to even more people because
they didn't recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means
the vaccines will get us to
the end of this joe biden spreading
misinformation
you're okay you're not gonna you're not
gonna get covet if you have these
vaccinations yeah really could we play
that again because maybe i didn't hear
it right maybe that was just me
you're okay you're not going to you're
not going to get covet if you have these
vaccinations yeah you're not going to
get coveted if you have these
vaccinations that is 100
of a lie that is misinformation that is
disinformation notice i never said that
on this show why didn't i say that on
this show when when people thought that
that was the truth when the cdc was
saying it when pfizer executives were
saying it when joe biden was saying it
how come i never came out and just
parroted what they said because i have
something called a brain and i thought
well i don't know just because a
pharmaceutical company is saying
something and just because the president
then repeats what the pharmaceutical
company is saying is how would i know
that that's actually true so
i waited and then by waiting you're not
going to believe this it turned out that
it wasn't true not only can you get
covid with the vaccines but you can
transmit covid with the vaccines of
course that's very different
than what cdc director rochelle wilinski
said a little while back
our data from the cdc today suggests um
you know that that vaccinated people do
not carry the virus don't get sick
and that it's not just in the clinical
trials but it's also in real world data
the point is that when they show
these warnings on things the warnings
only go one way right you guys all know
that the warnings only go one way and
rogan's gonna have to stand up now and
all of us that care about freedom that
care about our ability to discuss ideas
that care really just that that you are
allowed to make some kind of choice over
your life we better stand with rogan
right now it's as simple as that because
it ain't going to be easy whatever that
pressure is that's brought to bear on
him whatever the phone calls he's
getting from the spotify executives from
his agents
maybe the fan mail whatever it is or
just the mob like just the anonymous mob
that shows up on twitter and wherever
else they show up like it is pressure it
is real i have dealt with it to a degree
and everyone has a breaking point so uh
rogan i wish you the best of luck in
this whole thing all right let's move on
to this uh situation up in the great
white north of canada as you guys know
there has been this massive truck convoy
basically driving across canada
sometimes people are saying it's up
upwards of 50 000 trucks uh people
protesting the draconian lockdowns and
mandates by the justin trudeau
government we've got some more info here
from the post-millennial prime minister
justin trudeau has reportedly been
whisked away to a secret location as a
convoy of truckers has descended on
ottawa to protest the government's
vaccine mandates the independent reports
that the trudeau family has left their
residence due to security concerns over
the truckers who are currently
gridlocking the city with their trucks
honking their horns and participating in
protests including singing the national
anthem outside parliament that does
sound scary
trudeau has reportedly been in isolation
after one of his children tested
positive for covid okay so let's be
clear you can sort of see and canada has
a very perverse version of this because
so much of their mainstream media is
state funded you can see that they're
shifting the narrative here already it's
not just people who are sick of masks
sick of mandates sick of lockdowns
saying hey we're going to all come
together and we're going to protest
which is your right and free western
democracies now it's they're blocking
things and you know trudeau kind of
called them racist and they're spreading
misinformation and then trudeau had to
go into hiding because they want to make
it seem like these people are violent
like they're nazi adjacent etc etc well
we've got some video of those
nazi adjacent people as they arrived in
ottawa and you tell me what you see
[Music]
scary stuff isn't it they got to ottawa
they started dancing in the street there
were people and other people and they
were breathing on each other and smiling
and sharing joy and the desire to save
their country
freaking out over here my buddy ezra
levant from the rebel which is one of
the few independent media organizations
in canada he gave an absolutely
fantastic speech to the people of ottawa
we've got a little bit
because when people say what do we do
about the media
i say you become the media that's
[Music]
the media party it's a subsidiary of the
liberal party so you've got to tell the
story yourself everyone who was here
everyone who was along the road
has to bear witness and testify to what
they saw
because there's two competing narratives
the government says
you're racist the government chase your
sexes the government says you're violent
in the meantime
i've never seen a most diverse group of
canadians
they're far from violence people want to
not be violated anymore
justin trudeau says you're extreme
but he's the one who has violated our
civil rights
[Music]
well that's a pretty bloody big fringe
tell them what happened
tell them what you saw
because they will not hear the truth
from anyone
[Music]
that's freaking awesome i consider esla
ezra a friend he is a good man and that
is an inspirational speech by the way as
you know it's freezing in canada these
people would prefer
and as i mentioned on friday canadians
are pretty like calm and cool and
collected they would prefer to be inside
with a fire and some heating right but
they're out there saying we must fight
this evil insanity that is not stopping
that is closing our churches and our
schools and everything else he said a
couple things there and i want to quote
you become the media what a great line
guys all of you watching this
you are as powerful as the media you
know the media that has existed for a
long time maybe it was always lying to
us all all the time maybe it was i don't
know maybe it's only in the last 20 10
five years that because of technology
we've been able to expose them at the
level so now it seems like they lie
about everything maybe they've been
lying way longer about way more stuff
than we thought
we can have some separate discussions
about that but every single one of you
have a have a brain you have an opinion
you have a life you have thoughts and
you have a phone and you can get those
things out there at least for now right
and we're working on the tech solutions
to make sure that you'll be able to do
it long term
but he's right you're the media just
because the new york times prints
something just because some rag up in
canada prints something doesn't mean
it's true and they're preying on the
fact that we're all afraid to talk to
each other that we're all afraid to say
what we really think and the more that
we don't say what we think the more that
they feel that they can encroach he then
went on to say you've got to tell the
story yourself i love that there's a
story happening in the world and as that
jordan peterson guy who i may be doing a
little something with tonight in miami
often would say wouldn't you want to be
the main character in your story
wouldn't isn't that the best thing to be
when you watch a movie it's usually
about the main character that's why the
word maine is there he's the driver of
the whole freaking thing well you got a
chance and then finally bear witness to
what you saw do not believe that because
the canadian media or the new york times
or cnn tells you that those people out
there are racists and bigots and sexists
and even
anti-vaxxers or whatever whatever
ridiculous pejorative term they want to
use to describe those people who have
just been pushed far enough that they
had to create this convoy to drive
across a frozen tundra to get outside
and give speeches and dance with other
freedom-loving people don't believe
any of the nonsense that they are
pushing on you on all of that and if you
want to bear witness how about we end
this segment with a little inspiration a
little music and here is what baron
witness looks like
[Music]
we've got the right
[Music]
this is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
freaking awesome we're not going to take
it anymore that's what they did to the
good decent canadian the good decent
canadian who just wanted to live their
life they pushed them far enough that
this is what's going on so i just want
to be very clear about something i stand
with you good decent canadian i stand
with you
against justin trudeau and all of the
people who have done this to you 100
without equivocation
that's how i feel about all this and i'm
going to keep covering it and i believe
that if enough of us do if enough of us
bear witness if you on the ground bear
witness to what's going on if you on the
ground become the media then guess what
it starts traveling through the internet
and then some crazy guy in florida picks
it up and he talks about it on his show
and then next thing you know somebody
else talks about on their show next
thing you know something else happens
and then you change the world
why not right
speaking of change the world there is
something seriously interesting going on
over on hbo at real time with bill maher
obviously i've been spending a lot of
time talking about this that bill maher
represents a very small faction
of liberals who remain true to
liberalism i at this point might have
some political disagreements with bill i
would say i've shifted away from that
sort of pure liberal
position uh but i do agree with him on a
lot of things
and and what we agree or disagree on is
actually irrelevant bill represents what
a sane liberal is which is why so many
conservatives are often saying hey i
disagree with bill maher but he's right
on free speech he's right on mandates
blah blah blah blah blah well bill is
really going all in on this and he's
really picking a fight with the left and
this is what we've needed all along we
have needed the good liberals to step up
i tried for five years to try to get
enough good liberals to step up they
kind of couldn't do it they're afraid of
their own shadow i think there's reasons
for that there are flaws in liberalism
in and of itself
but bill's doing it and credit is due
and i'm going to give the guys some
credit so this is a little portion uh
friday night on real time with bill
maher people sometimes say to me you
know you didn't you didn't used to make
fun of the left as much
yeah because they didn't give me so much
to work with
when
normal people read that san francisco
has basically legalized shoplifting
they think democrats have gone nuts
they think
you know that ted cruz cruz guy
seems like a real stiff
but at least he believes in the concept
of shopping with money
it's not
it's not my fault that the party of fdr
and jfk is turning into the party of lol
and wtf
[Applause]
members of congress
tweeting things like cancel rent
cancel mortgage and no more policing or
incarceration
declaring that capitalism is slavery
canceling lincoln and dr seuss teaching
children their oppressors and math is
racist making mr potato head
gender-neutral
and now an emoji for pregnant men
real i'm not making it up
yeah
you get it bill the problem that
you and i are having or let's say the
the difference of opinion or difference
of conclusion is that at the end you got
to stop voting for these people and at
the end the problem is that it has
infested the entire democratic party and
the problem is that there aren't enough
good democrats old-school jfk
daniel patrick moynihan ed koch old
school classical liberals left they are
now i would say the moderate part of the
conservative movement i would include
myself in that so you know he talks
about ted cruz there and it's like yes
he makes a little joke about ted cruz
but then in essence he's saying yeah ted
cruz says you have to you know pay for
stuff with money in essence meaning oh
ted cruz believes in the rule of law
believes in capitalism
believes that this thing that we're all
doing is pretty decent and that's better
than the democrats but
it's like
until you're willing to say i might vote
for someone like ted cruz then we still
have a problem now i want to give bill
more room by the way to to make that
adjustment right so it's like last week
we did the video where he was talking
about florida saying how great it is in
florida but then he said i'm not moving
to florida and it's like
bill
bill maybe you should move to florida
you live in los angeles which is a
[ __ ] run by these people who show up
to sofi stadium without masks while they
put everyone else in masks so so that's
a bit of a disconnect there it's like
what's at the end so bill went on to
talk about why the people on the right
like him so much lately
a few weeks ago fox news's dana perino a
former bush press secretary suggested
that the democrats
should recruit me to run for president
which is kind of special seeing the cso
mar is recruited to run for
the presidency
let's get this straight it's not me
who's changed it's the left
who is now made up of a small contingent
who've gone mental and a large
contingent who refused to call them out
for it but i will that's why i'm a hero
at fox these days
[Applause]
which shows just how much liberals have
their head up their ass because if they
really thought about it they would have
made me a hero on their media
okay i think i'm a bit of an expert on
this as the why i left the left guy have
you seen the video it's on the youtube
and i wrote a whole book defending
classical liberalism um but there's a
couple interesting things here first off
the fact that dana perino on fox news is
saying you know bill maher should run
for president shows you that
conservatives actually like disagreement
with people in a sane way like
conservatives i see this all the time
all the time
people come up to me on the street and
say what dave what happened to the old
school liberals we used to like arguing
about things okay so they were
pro-choice we were pro-life okay they
wanted more taxes we wanted less taxes
but what happened to those people you
could argue with decently and they're
pretty much gone so what i think bill is
missing there he's calling the radicals
a small element and the and the good
liberals he's saying they're the
majority i don't think so anymore and if
they are the majority if they're the
silent majority and they won't do jack
[ __ ] about it
then there's a problem now to that point
i again applaud bill for standing up
against this this is a fight worth
taking and for all these years
where i was say shifting or realizing
where there was fertile ground for ideas
and where i could make allies versus the
scorched earth i always said you could
find probably 50 videos of me saying if
my liberal friends prove me wrong if
they can actually save the democratic
party from this nonsense i will gladly
have a maya culpa absolutely i'll be
like boy i really missed the ball on
that one you guys sure were right you
really did stop the woksters but there's
no evidence of it so when the when he
talks about san francisco crumbling or
all these democratic places crumbling
the good liberals don't have the
wherewithal to stop it and what the
problem is so what that leads us to in
the final conclusion is unless you are
going to support glenn younkin in
virginia who's running against critical
race theory
and unless you are going to support ron
desantis who's keeping the state open
if you are going to not support the
people who are doing the whole freaking
thing but you're just going to
constantly say i'm still a liberal these
people are all idiots but somehow you
can't really vote for the people who
were doing the right thing because
they're racist or they believe in god or
they're morons or something
then there's a problem but i will
continue to try to have this
conversation
because i think it's an important one to
have i think we all have to think these
things through and and by the way the
difference here as you can see is not
really a difference of opinion sure
there's some
there's some difference of political
opinion between what bill maher believes
and would say a conservative believes or
even what i believe this is a difference
about tactics and i would also say and
then i'll move on is that
maybe and i think this is what bill is a
little bit confused by maybe there is a
fundamental flaw in liberalism and i've
talked about this a bit and this was not
something that i wanted to to accept
but this is something that i think that
jordan peterson helped me fully evolve
on that a purely secular liberalism that
has no truth outside of itself that has
no truth outside of what man believes
will end up believing almost anything so
while bill is railing against the trans
stuff and the woke stuff it's like
maybe that is just an extension of what
secularism secular
godless sort of liberalism leads to and
there are a few people
a few people who as individuals can
behave in a certain moral framework and
build something really good and truly
liberal without a bigger structure
behind it or above it or around it but
most people cannot and societies can't
so everywhere that liberals move to
become these horrible places and it's
not because liberals are bad people it's
not because the idea of liberalism is
wrong it's because it's maybe not
holistic enough so again i would love to
continue to have that conversation and
hopefully have it with bill at some
point i sense that that is in the works
i've said too much uh okay let's move on
to the final story uh lindsey graham
senator lindsey graham who's been uh you
know in the senate forever basically
he's run for president a couple of times
he sometimes kind of gets it as a
conservative as a republican and then
sometimes doesn't get it well he's back
to the doesn't get it part uh as you
know uh supreme court justice stephen
breyer is stepping down we covered that
last week and joe biden has said that
he's going to have a black woman replace
her because of course that's what we
care about most here in the united
states here's joe himself the person i
will nominate will be someone with
extraordinary qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
so joe wants a black woman replacing
steven breyer who happens to be a white
man now i don't believe that a supreme
court seat is owned by any one person i
certainly don't believe it's owned by
anyone's skin color or gender but
ironically saying that you're going to
give a job to someone based on the color
of their skin and by their gender is
actually against the civil rights act of
1963 63 or 64. i always get that civil
rights act is it 63 or 64. give me a
number on that um
so already we're doing something very
bad here now how do i link this to
lindsey graham well you'd think that
every sane conservative or or just sort
of every sane freedom-loving person
would be against this idea that we would
be injecting race into who we hire and
to who gets confirmed as a supreme court
justice the civil rights act 1964. i
will lock that in the brain going
forward uh but lindsey graham no he's
completely fine with biden's idea here
the idea that we're gonna have just a
black woman be the next president reagan
said
running for office that he wanted to put
the first female on the court whether
you like it or not joe biden said i'm
going to pick an african-american woman
to serve on the supreme court i believe
there are plenty of qualified
african-american women conservative and
liberal that could go onto the court so
i don't concede i don't see michelle
chiles as an act of affirmative action i
do see putting a black woman on the
court making the court more like america
in the history of our country
we've only had five women serve and two
african-american men
man sorry lindsey graham you're exactly
the type of politician that we don't
need anymore
you really are we don't need that
pandering drivel nobody is saying that
there aren't
thousands
thousands literally probably hundreds of
thousands of qualified black women to
sit on the supreme court great legal
minds etc etc nobody's saying that
everyone knows that that is
but as a
marker as the original starting point
that here is the pool that i will select
from we have a giant pool but my pool
will just be black women it's not that
you're not going to pick the best person
because the back the best person might
be a black woman but first it's against
the law it's against the law to hire
based on skin color and gender that's
number one a law by the way that had a
little something to do with the supreme
court in the first place but also this
pandering drivel that's why you're
becoming irrelevant lindsey graham this
pandering trivial that it will be a
black woman well why not a native
american woman why not an indian woman i
mean indian from india woman why not an
asian woman are there any chinese
american supreme court justices korean
supreme court justices but no why do we
keep going to that group of people could
it be because we're the ones that
actually
want to basically bribe them
we want to endlessly bribe them so that
they'll keep voting for us because
otherwise none of our policies actually
work for them and lindsey graham you're
now part of it you're part of it so this
is this is neo-racism there is no one
and this is one of the things to get to
the previous segment that i would want
bill maher to come around to there is no
one on the right in mainstream on the
right who wants anyone judged by the
color of their skin that isn't to say
that there aren't some far right races
somewhere
there are
but there is no one mainstream there is
no thought leader there is no politician
that wants people treated differently
based on the color of their skin their
gender and at this point even their
sexuality but it is a mainstream idea on
the left it is within the ethos of the
democratic party and i wish bill maher
luck fixing that because he's going
against joe biden and he's going
basically against republican light but i
would say at this point basically
democrat lindsey graham as well
all right guys i think we had a full
show today i got a long day of doing
stuff at the house and fixing up some
studio stuff and a bunch more and then
as i said if you can still get tickets
perhaps
dave rubin is going to be the surprise
opening act for jordan peterson this
evening perhaps
and it's a big surprise you know big
surprise uh
but before we finish up you know every
monday at the reuben report community we
do meme monday over there where we get
people to share their favorite meme of
the week this is how we kick off the
week here's my meme from today
i hope my government will let me go
outside today i felt that that was sort
of appropriate in light of all the
the covid stuff and the spotify stuff
the rogan stuff the canada stuff and the
rest of it and now hundreds of people
are throwing their memes in so if you'd
like to join us it's a fun way to kick
off the week you can go to
roomreport.locals.com
uh part three of my interview with
florida senator marco rubio is up on
youtube and rumble right now the full
episode is already up at
reubenreport.locals.com
all right we've got a full day today
hope you
enjoy the day i hope your week gets off
to a good start and we'll do it again
tomorrow
ciao
you